of course public health officials tell
us the way New York is going now could
come to the rest of the country but
there's a patchwork of stay-at-home
orders and directives all around this
nation that have created dramatic
differences in the way we live in the
way we travel then york times made this
map using anonymous cell phone data take
a look the red areas show states where
travel patterns are normal or close to
normal now take a look at the Northeast
and parts of the Midwest you can see
there is little or no travel in states
that imposed very strict stay-at-home
orders ed O'Keefe is in Washington
forest where he typically covers
politics not pandemics but these days
there's some overlap between the two at
good morning so what do you make of this
contrast well look President Trump isn't
issuing a national stay of home order
saying that each state should act on its
own but that isn't stopping some local
officials from pushing for more this
will go down in history as a profound
failure of our national government
governors like Illinois JB Pritzker won
a national stay at home order in terms
of state action state orders we've
nearly exhausted every avenue available
the calls are coming despite the
Constitution leaving most health and
public safety concerns to state and
local officials the tension between
federally mandated vs. states rights to
do what they want is something I don't
want to get into but even dr. Anthony
found she agreed there should be a
national order if you look at what's
going on in this country I just don't
understand why we're not doing that 40
states and the District of Columbia have
issued some kind of stay at home order
over the past month
despite information as far back as
February about patients being
asymptomatic the governor of Georgia
waited until Wednesday to issue his
statewide order individuals can be
infected and begin to spread coronavirus
earlier than previously thought even if
they have no symptoms from a public
health standpoint this is a revelation
this week Texas governor Greg Abbott
also ordered schools closed through May
4th and said that only essential
services can remain open but he insisted
this is not a stay at home strategy
local officials like Dallas County
leader clay Jenkins saying Abbott should
have acted sue
he issued a countywide order back on
March 22nd why did you decide to do you
have to follow the science in situations
like this and the hospitals and doctors
uniformly told me that safer at home
would save lives and in Ohio Republican
Governor Mike DeWine
has earned praise for acting quickly you
seemed pretty insistent from the start
that there was a real genuine public
health and safety concern well
everything I was told by the experts was
that you have to act early and that even
waiting a week or two weeks before you
act
really sets you way way back and
increases the number of deaths all of
these stay-at-home orders are of course
of course causing the rescheduling of
events even in campaign politics the
Democratic Party now says that its
convention to nominate someone to take
on President Trump will be held in
mid-august in Milwaukee Gail that's
interesting Edie may I just say it's
very good to see you thank you sir